bonjour je vais commencer par me
présentait déjà
donc j'ai joué j'ai joël bonjour je
m'appelle joël j'ai 24 ans j'ai un
enfant je suis danseur expérimental et
aujourd'hui c'est la première année où
je peux dire que je suis professionnel
voilà je voulais juste préciser ça parce
qu'on va revenir un petit peu en arrière
et je vous parlais du début donc comment
j'ai commencé donc je suis cuisinier
j'ai 19 ans je m'appelle toujours joël
mais j'ai pas d'enfant donc ce qui se
passe c'est que au niveau de la société
je suis dans cette case là artisanat
métiers d'un garçon je suis métisse
franco gabonais je le précise que ça
nous aidera plus tard et en fait je me
demande qu'est ce que je fais dans la
vie
pourquoi je fais ça pourquoi la cuisine
quand j'étais petit je voulais
biochimiste qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
ne sais pas mais il ya eu des
changements et je me suis dit je voulais
un métier où je puisse exprimer quelque
chose je puisse rencontrer les autres
c'était presque ça donc il ya eu un
changement j'ai arrêté la cuisine et je
me suis retrouvé dans la danse un peu
par hasard
j'arrive au centquatre et je découvre je
précise le centquatre c'est une salle
sur paris où il ya énormément de
discipline qui s'exprime dans le même
endroit
donc j'arrive là-bas j'ai jamais vu ça
je vois du cirque de la danse du théâtre
de la musique ok
je vais danser
donc je me retrouve première expérience
de danse où je suis tout seul mais je
suis là pour moi je kiffe voilà ok je
vais danser j'aime ça j'aime ça et je
commence à tomber amoureux de la danse
mais assez brutalement c'est qui ça
passe de un jour de découvert à trois
mois intensifs où j allais tous les
jours sans m'arrêter je comprenais pas
pourquoi c'est la première fois de ma
vie où je pouvais exprimer quelque chose
aussi aussi personnellement aussi
frontalement et j'avais pas besoin de
réfléchir à qui je suis pourquoi je fais
ça et pour qui je le fais je le fais
pour moi c'est tout et c'est là où
arrive ma première rencontre avec la
danse dans le monde du hip hop avec ma
première formation la flo dance academy
qui est juste là et c'était intense
c'était intense j'ai fait un an et demi
dans une école qui s'appelle donc flou
dance et c'était pas exactement ce à
quoi je m'attendais je vais vous montrer
un petit exemple de danse hip hop
qu'est ce qu'on appelle la danse hip hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
souffle et c'est là où en fait
j'apprends que la danse c'est frontal ça
se dirige dans un seul sens il ya des
codes des informations un langage
spécifique
donc je connaissais pas la danse avant
ça j'ai commencé à 19 ans et donc c'est
mon idée que je me fais de la danse
annoncé comme ça c'est une boîte c'est
une nouvelle boîte c'est pas libre j'ai
un col j'ai des codes
j'ai une identité à travers ça parce que
très souvent quand je dis je suis
danseur a tué dit popp
oui ah bah je savais pas je pensais pas
que mon apparence défini c'est mon style
en fait et c'est là où j'ai commencé à
poser des questions ahmad ans j'avais
pas de l'interlocuteur ou de personnel
qui ait changé ça je fais pas partie
d'un crew jamais évolué dans le monde
des battles pourtant je me demandais
mais il ya bien un endroit où on peut
s'exprimer autrement on peut vraiment
être libre comme à ce moment où j'ai
découvert la danse soit 104 quand j'ai
appris en fait à rencontrer tout ça et
c'est là où je me suis tourné vers le
clubbing avec la danse house qui fait
partie de j-pop aujourd'hui mais c'est
notre histoire et je me suis dit bon il
ya quelque chose c'est la musique je
sais pas mais il ya un truc qui bouge
différemment
oh
[Musique]
c
c'est
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
bon jeu censé avoir assez de souffle
mais ça revient et donc là je découvre
une nouvelle forme un nouveau rapport à
l'espace et je me pose une question qui
définit la danse ton identité
aujourd'hui c'est la formation tout à
fait c'est les gens avec qui tu parles
ton cercle privé ou le plus grand tué
qui cette question vient vraiment
raisonnée et arrive la naissance de ma
fille s'appelle caloy donc j'ai 21 ans
un enfant c'est la panique
je viens de changer de métier donc j'ai
tout recommencé à zéro dans la danse ça
paye pas au début on sait tous
donc je suis en mode bon qu'est ce que
je fais
j'arrête je continue qu'est ce que je
fais je suis reparti poser cette
question là à la danse et j'arrive en
endroit intéressant où je découvre le
mouvement en soit le mouvement animale
grâce aux arts martiaux et je
m'interroge sur la posture et si on
pouvait travailler le mouvement dans son
ensemble avec un état avec comme si on
était un endroit fixe avec une pause
statique
est-ce que ça développe quelque chose
comme à l'image de la vie est ce qu un
moment où on va avoir une pause on peut
continuer d'avancer
est ce que c'est possible donc là je
partis dans mes recherches et me suis
dis pas je vais aller chercher l'origine
des choses dans la musique dans tout ça
dans le mouvement pour trouver des
réponses d'être mieux comprendre en fait
le présent parce que c'est une forme
c'est une manière de demander à mon
passé qu'est ce qui se passe qui tu es
qu'est-ce que tu représentes dans le
trop de questions dont j'ai simplifié et
je me suis dit ok ces danseurs hip hop à
21 ans
mes thèmes autre chose et tu fais pour
qui
pour toi j'avais pas encore pourquoi je
dansais mais j'avais au moins une
réponse claire c'est juste dance pour
moi ça fait du bien et donc je reviens
aux danses un peu plus classique
on va dire un peu plus ancienne la base
du hip hop dont tout ce qu'ils font que
les fang style etc
je commence à comprendre l'évolution du
hip hop le hip hop n'est pas juste un
style ses six danses différentes pop
rock hip hop break house maintenant et
après jeudi 6 mai il a souvent des
petits mélange parce qu'on parle de
danse urbaine le krump et dans le hip
hop ou pas non le crep fait partie du
hip hop il ya le courant hip hop qui
englobe un petit peu tout ça donc pour
revenir sur ça j'arrive au funk et c'est
là où je découvre notre style musical et
je m'approche d'autres mouvements
oh
[Musique]
on
on va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un petit mélange de plusieurs
styles grossièrement mélanger mais c'est
une manière de montrer en fait on
percevra très souvent le mouvement juste
par une identité simple ok qu'est ce qui
est fun qu qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas et
quand je dis funk je pense qu'on a tous
une référence musicale
la musique c'est ce qui parle la plupart
du monde déjà on le dit souvent hockey
ces choses là mais c'est un peu plus
riche que ça parce que la naissance de
tous ces styles ses musiques et très
connecté donc quand on apprend n'est pas
de salsa
peut-être qu'on fait de la house quand
on apprend du lot king ou du popping
être qu'on apprend des fonks thème
qu'est ce que font ces thèmes qu'est ce
que la banque
qu'est ce que c'est quoi ces trucs très
souvent le mot ou même l'expression même
latitude on la connaît on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya derrière
et c'est ça qui m'a fait me poser comme
question c'est quoi la danse aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on identifie et à travers
ça où est mon identité
donc j'arrive à l'étape suivante où je
me dis je vais tout mettre à zéro parce
que je suis pas un expert en mouvement
je suis pas si je suis pas ça et je
m'inspirais des arts martiaux et du
mouvement le plus neutre possible je
vais remonter avant ça et je me suis
demandé d'où vient la danse comment a
commencé la danse cetera et cetera et je
me suis dit moi je vais prendre un
départ parce qu'on a pas vraiment de
réponse claire et je vais partir du
mouvement illimité limitation animal en
fait comment interpréter le mouvement
par l'animal par le mouvement de la
nature dont je suis parti avec un
élément simple et c'est là où les pauses
rentrer en jeu c'est la marche
mais laquelle
y'a pas de musique vous inquiétez pas
je parlais plus fort je suis à partir de
cette base la question l'allemand qui
hélas se déplace la menace peut on à ce
rapport va mouiller en avance c'est en
dessous de zéro mais qu'est ce que je
fais avec ça ce que je peux danser place
inventant ces mouvements importants cet
amas donc quel que soit ton attitude tu
peux crier en fait quelque chose que le
singe gorille et j'installe cette
première question
voilà mais j'ai passé presque trois mois
promo et demi à ne faire que ça c'était
une manière en fait de sortir de tout ce
qu'on m'avait appris de tous les codes
que j'avais dans la tête et je pensais
que la danse et la société était séparé
d'une certaine manière mais on a tous
nos repères moi je parle des miens pour
préciser quand même la chose c'est on a
une manière de se questionner sur qu'est
ce que je vais devenir qu'est ce que je
suis qu'est ce que je vais être et donc
ce premier grand mur qui arrive c'est je
veux devenir professionnel dans la danse
mais je me limite pas au hip hop
j'aime funk house hip hop mouvement
animal et le contemporain vient de
rencontrer mais musicalement je suis pas
encore dans tous les styles
donc je retourne quand même à quelque
chose mais je m'exprime différemment
[Musique]
à
ça vient m'aider à comprendre ce que je
cherche à faire de la danse comme on
cherche à exprimer
que cherche à réellement dire et c'est
là où je commence à comprendre pourquoi
je fais ça vous cherchez à exprimer et
donc il me faut un pseudo pour évoluer
fallait une identité secrète
je vais faire des trucs de super héros
mais j'ai pas de cap j'ai pas de slip
moulant c'est pas possible
fodé collant une fois un truc c'est là
où cruz vient et je me demande hockey
comment en un mot comme en un mouvement
tu peux résumer ton parcours ton chemin
ou juste que tu veux exprimer ce que tu
veux partager avec les autres et au
cross ça me paraissait bien mais je
comprenais pas trop pourquoi je dis ça
fait style et c'est cool alors que bon
par des gens qui parle couramment
anglais m'ont dit mais le dans une
phrase non ça veut rien dire comme chris
brown le hockey j'ai fait bon je vais
réfléchir c'est l'eau la danse
expérimentale prend tout son sens parce
qu'à l'époque s'appelait pas encore ça
comme ça j'avais pas ce que c'était je
n'ai pas été aussi vieux que la danse
expérimentale ça fait quand même plus de
dix ans voire 20 ans que ça existe bien
et c'est une association juste de
plusieurs danses très souvent on parle
de danse expérimentale quand il
rencontre contemporain hip hop
contemporain quelque chose que la danse
contemporaine a amorcé très tôt ce
langage
cette non cet échange entre les langages
je parle espagnol tu parle italien je
parle anglais tu parle français mais on
peut communiquer ensemble c'est ça en
fait on essaye de faire et c'est là où
j'arrive en fait à une étape où je vais
pousser le truc encore plus loin j'ai
utilisé les musiques que moi j'aime que
j'écoute secrètement parce qu'avant de
rentrer dans le hip hop musicalement non
plus j'écoute est pas du tout ça comme
vous disais j'ai été surpris parce que
je suis métisse je suis danseur danseurs
hip hop
non je ne fais pas des
j'ai pas leur dire ça y est ok oui
certains j'ai raté le casting beaucoup
passent à la suite c'est là où le
mouvement évolué
[Musique]
non
je
[Musique]
je pense
johanna mali
[Musique]
on fait quoi
[Applaudissements]
je commence à incorporer des choses qui
ne sont pas spécialement hip hop
l'impact j'adore ça la basse le
mouvement mais c'est codifié je fais de
la house j'ai pas loin d'être agressif
je fais la house joie est doux et
délicat
je danse je survole le sol tu gracieux
que les choses comme ça et le
contemporain m'a vraiment fait réfléchir
sur l'importance de ce mouvement et
cette base là donc mais mon identité
s'est remise en question est ce que je
suis juste un danseur de 23 ans qui aime
le hip hop musiques électroniques la
musique classique
le hard métal japonais oui j'en ai
écoutés et c'est là où tout se conjugue
est tout doux cendriers et je me dis ok
pourquoi pas faire mon truc montrer qui
je suis et vraiment donner du sens à ce
mot là donc quelque chose devient mon
pseudo est j'amorce donc la première
année professionnelle
je vais en italie d'abord pour présenter
ma recherche sur le mouvement animal
l'egypte je reviens tout juste du gabon
où j'ai eu la chance de chorégraphier un
show et c'est là où on fait je me rends
compte que ce qui est important c'est le
message est pas le mouvement
c'est ce que je vais faire avec et ça
peut marcher que n'importe quel métier
n'importe quelle discipline n'importe
quelle base ça vient de là en fait
qu'est-ce que vous allez chercher à
l'intérieur de ça qu'est ce que vous
dites le matin quand vous levez je fais
ça pour moi je sais pas pour les autres
pourquoi je fais ça et je pense qu'on a
tous eu ces épreuves-là qui peuvent nous
réveiller ou nous pousse à aller autre
part moi ça a été son chemin dans fait
socialement parlant qui je suis pour qui
vise à vide qui comment je me suis en
âge où on se construit sur plein
d'aspects d'avoir un enfant ça m'a
renforcé ça m'a vraiment structuré et
c'est là où j'ai autorisé la la forme a
évolué et j'arrive à un endroit de un
moment de pause et de calme où j'ai pu
en fait vraiment libéré ce mouvement et
dire d'accord c'est comme ça que je veux
danser
c'est avec ça et je veux tout mélanger
sans prendre la tête
[Musique]
sauf qu'elle
des stands jusqu'au faux
[Musique]
c
pas assez
est ce que c'est
[Musique]
une sorte de 1,6
et demi
parce que nous
[Musique]
la fin de vie
merci